welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka your friendly
neighborhood spoiler man and we now have
a new post-credit scene for spider-man
far from home that made its way to the
web through Jay jonah Jameson's very
young website The Daily Bugle dotnet
this awesome addition adds a lot to the
movie and teases what could happen in
the upcoming films spider-man 3 as well
as just how mad your boy Triple J is at
spider-man we're gonna play the clip in
just a bit but before we break it down I
have to give the warning that there will
be heavy spoilers here so if you haven't
seen far from home yet
one what the hell are you doing here and
two or go and watch it and bring me
pictures of spider-man this will ruin
the ending of the movie so this is your
last chance to back out without the way
huge thank you for clicking this video
now let's get into the breakdown okay so
the scene is entirely new
never-before-seen footage unless you've
already seen it before
that talks more in depth about the
reveal that Peter Parker is indeed
spider-man the clip is just over 30
seconds long and I'm guessing it was
going to go right after the cut that we
got Peter Parker shouting what the f but
that's probably a better way to end the
movie that ties more in with the ending
of homecoming and the big reveal in that
it's pretty funny anyway so without
further ado let's get into the clip
Queens name Peter Parker a teenage
psychopath armed to the teeth
for some reason is an army weaponized
drones wielding powers he has no right
to possess trying to pass himself off as
a hero you are a criminal a menace and
the good people of this nation will
squash you like the bug you are
okay jonah Jameson here thanks for
watching
don't forget to Like and subscribe okay
so that's the post-credits scene it's
short but sweet and there's actually
quite a lot to unpack from it and some
new announcements that we've had over
the past week firstly there's a quick
shot in the clip of a newspaper article
that we see from the Daily Bugle net
that actually points out how the world
views Mysterio in the wake of the attack
on London most authority figures
probably know that the villain was
actually the one that orchestrated it
all and it looks like the truth is
making its way around the world with a
paragraph that reads Quentin Beck was
not born on earth at least not our earth
but he gave His life protecting it if
only the people weren't fed such lies
about him this makes it seem that at
least there is some stance against the
villain with probably the majority of
the world knowing that spider-man isn't
a murderer and that Mysterio was just a
master illusionist that tried to prop
himself up as a hero now going forward
this could definitely be used as a way
for Peter Parker to downplay his part in
the death of the character and if there
is indeed people out there that know the
truth and believed that he had no
involvement in it and it may even be
possible for the character to team up
with some of the MCU heroes in order to
clear his name I'm glad this line was at
least put somewhere as pretty much all
of the Avengers and characters at the
end of endgame will know that Peter
Parker is a good kid and not the kind of
guy to launch a drone attack so it's
great that the public are starting to
get this understanding and it could
definitely be an element that clears the
character's name however if the heroes
do decide to work with spider-man then
where does that leave Jay jonah Jameson
in the clappy says that the good people
of the nation will squash Peter like the
bug that he is and this could also be
setting up things in the Sony verse now
we did have reports earlier in the week
that Jay jonah Jameson is going to be
the first MCU character to cross over
into the spider verse and that he will
be making an appearance in the upcoming
movie Morbius starring Jared Leto is a
Leto is at the Jared Leto I don't know
anyway in that after failing to gain
people behind his cause he could in fact
turn to the villain and there is
precedence in the comics for Jay jonah
Jameson to get spider-man's villains to
attack the webhead most notably JJ was
the one who
scorpion access to all of his technology
and I would love to see that plot
aesthetic pop up in the MCU JJ is gonna
be a pivotal character that connects the
two universes and bridges them together
this could also mean that Morbius could
potentially be setting up some events
that happen in spider-man 3 and I would
be very surprised if Tom Holland or at
least a mention of spider-man didn't pop
up in that movie hinting at what could
be coming in the third MCU film for the
wall crawler it's exciting times as
always with spider-man and I really
can't wait to see what happens down the
line especially now that we know that
he's back in the MCU now obviously I'd
love to hear your thoughts on this scene
and what you hope to see in the future
do you think that spider-man is the true
villain of the series do you have
pictures of spider-man are you best
mates with spider-man comment below and
let me know and if you enjoyed this
video then please give it a thumbs up
and make sure you check out my breakdown
of the plot leaks that we have on the
upcoming Falcon and Winter Soldier show
that will be linked at the end if you
want to come chat to me after the video
then make sure you follow me on twitter
at definition whitey or head over to my
discord server which will be linked in
the description below those are the best
ways to keep up to date with all the
latest videos on the channel so
hopefully I see you over there very soon
we're also giving away a free copy of
the Marvel phase 3 pot one box and
blu-ray which contains Civil War Doctor
Strange homecoming Ragnarok and more and
guess what all you have to do to be in
with a chance of winning is like the
video make sure that you subscribe to
the channel and leave your thoughts on
this post-credit scene in the comment
section below
the winners gonna be chosen on the 15th
of November and the set will be shipped
out from then - ever gets the prize so
best of luck to everyone who takes part
this is a channel for people who are
super into superheroes so if that's the
kind of thing you like hit subscribe
thanks again for taking the time to
watch this I've been definition you've
been the best and I'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]
[Music]